so we've been building um a big water
system to send we have a lot of
elevation change in this property
there's several probably 500 feet from
top to bottom or 400 and something feet
so we're we have a spring at the bottom
so we've been sending that water up high
and then storing it high and then using
it to gravity feed through like
irrigated pastures and you know I I kind
of have this dream of building a small
hydroelectric plant like just like a 2in
PVC pipe with a hydroelectric plant so
you know at night I can spring that
water back down the hill and create
power at night which is what my problem
is now right I have so much power during
the day but nothing at night so if I can
send the water uphill and at night pull
it back down through a hydro little
hydrop plant and just feed my system
then then I'm fully so you know I never
need that generator to turn on do you
also irrigate along the way yeah you can
so then we'd pull it down and then we'd
we we'd go even further and irrigate
farther down with it so um you know with
the animal
right now we don't
have like we could we could probably
keep growing our herd a little bit but